everybody seven o'clock how are you all
feeling this morning heartbreak for
Wales as England knocks them out of
their first World Cup in 64 years will
bring you all the reaction live from
Qatar as the Lions go through to the
final 16. also ahead hopes of a
breakthrough for Alzheimer's as a new
drug is shown to slow memory decline for
the first time plus ambulance workers
vote to go on strike as the wave of
industrial action just keeps on growing
speaking to the union and the boss of
NHS providers about the impact on the
Health Service lots to come busy show
Wednesday the 30th of November
ecstasy and Agony as England not whales
out of the World Cup
hello from Qatar the morning after the
night before England Victorious are
through to the next round but Wales are
going home
speaking to Young fans as Wales is World
Cup dream comes to an end
momentous and historic hopes after a new
drug is found in Trials to slow the
progress of early stage Alzheimer's
ambulance workers in England are set to
strike Before Christmas could it
coincide with the planned nurses
walkouts
I'm on the High Street as food prices
rise at a record rate as inflation soars
to 12.4 percent
NATO promises more arms for Kiev and
equipment to help Ukraine restore power
and heat knocked out by Russian
airstrikes
[Music]
foreign England is through to the final
16 of the World Cup in Qatar after
beating Wales three Nils second half
last night and ending the Dragons World
Cup dreams while the Welch Team Heads
home from their first World Cup in 64
years the lions are now preparing to
face Senegal on Sunday population 11
million here's the moment England fans
saw their team score last night
[Applause]
Farm celebration in box Park Wembley we
also caught reaction from both Wales and
England supporters outside the stadium
in Doha
what can you say absolutely terrible no
driving no passion what can you say they
have to rebuild with uh some some uh
some of the younger players and uh start
again for the Euros but Hope Springs
Eternal mate it was kind of a bit easy
really if I'm honest sorry what else
fans
oh she might live to regret that our
Middle East correspondent Aleister
bunkel joining us now from Doha hi
Alistair good morning to you football
coming home certainly as far as Wales is
concerned
we're outside the Wales team Hotel this
morning they will be going home we think
at some point later today uh knocked out
of the World Cup bottom of the group
only managed to score one point and
frankly they were very much second best
against England last night it was in a
way As the adage goes a game of two
halves England were dominant in the
first half controlling possession and
wearing whales down but in the second
half that's when they made the advantage
count and scored those three goals to go
top of the group and through to the next
round whereas you say they'll face
Senegal No Easy Task but topping the
group has put England in a good position
to progress through in this tournament
they're not training today I think it's
going to be a day off for them to try
and rest their legs they've got four
days off or at least four days before
their next match against Senegal on
Sunday so they'll be using every bit of
those four days to try and recharge the
batteries and make sure they're fresh
for Sunday's match
okay just looking at the images actually
as we're chatting I mean uh if you could
hear a pin drop around most of the
country last night I was trying to rush
home to get to watch the anthems just
miss them but there was literally nobody
on the streets here in London that can't
even begin to imagine you want to be
like if they progressed further than the
uh last 16. who is tell me about
senegals what do we know about them
well said I got a quite a good side I
mean they have progressed before in the
World Cup before the West African side
passionate passionate footballing nation
and so I don't think and I know that
when we speak to Gareth Southgate later
in the week you know he'll tell you what
he'd expect him to tell you that this is
not a team to be underestimated the
benefit of course of qualifying first in
the group as England have done is mean
they do face the slightly lesser team in
Senegal uh rather than the Netherlands
who qualified uh at the top of that
group and so it'll be the United States
who will face Netherlands England will
face uh Senegal and I think Senegal have
got quite an attacking uh bent to them
so they'll be uh I will see whether or
not Southgate does what he did yesterday
and tries to shore up the Midfield with
the likes of Jordan Henson in there
which which works so well last night
um and just before I let you go um
Alistair thought about um that young lad
Marcus rashford
um some commentators rather clumsily
saying he's now concentrating on his
football I mean he does an awful lot of
uh good work for youngsters up in
Manchester and indeed around the country
as well when it comes to trying to
support them with free School meals but
he certainly showed his class last night
oh yeah I mean two fantastic goals I
mean that first free kick uh rocketed
into the far corner of the net on the
second goal uh was also England's 100th
goal in World Cups Max rashford is a
hugely talented player hugely talented
forward he has had a couple of off
seasons for whatever reason and people
probably unfairly may be pointing to the
fact that maybe he was distracted
elsewhere away from football but
whatever it is that is not the case at
the moment he's back on form for his
Club Manchester United and he's very
much back on form for England
he was started last night for the first
time I think our Southgate will find it
very hard to leave him out of the
starting 11 come Sunday yeah he's
yeah he's paid the gaffer didn't he
thanks very much indeed Alistair in Doha
let's bring in Becky who's standing by
as we can see in Wales a school in Wales
oh goodness they're not going to be very
happy this morning are they
no welcome to Monmouth prep school where
pupils are allowed to stay up last night
and watch the match there are some tired
children coming into school this morning
and very disappointed particularly
amongst the Welsh fans let's bring in
two of them still wearing their Wales
flags with pride I'm pleased to see boys
we've got nine-year-old twins here Dylan
and Alice
um what did you make of the match last
night I think it was a good match but it
was not too good for wears in the first
half but they kept on going in the
second half which was good for them yeah
and I know one of you said to me you did
confess that once they started to lose
three nil you decided just to give up
and go to bed yeah that's true yeah now
you two you're kind of wild super fans
because you were actually in Qatar
weren't you the Headmaster here allowed
you to have some time off school to go
over there with your family and you saw
the game against the USA so that was
when the whale stream was still very
much alive tell us about that so um in
the first half USA scored and the rose
wasn't playing that good but in the
second half Wales got a penalty and then
gabbez scored it so we drew so so hopes
are so high then and obviously now the
Wales team coming home it's quite
disappointing isn't it yeah it is but
it's I'm just really glad that they made
into the World Cup this far yeah and you
two were lucky enough to go there and
see it in person weren't you well thank
you so much for getting up early to
speak to us after your late night
watching the game and all the
disappointment um in actual fact
although this school's in Monmouth it is
a boarding school so actually you'll see
the England flag on the bunting here
because there was a split of about 50 50
last night so pretty good atmosphere I'm
told it was very friendly uh Noah you
were among the England fans watching
um tell us what you made of the match oh
I think it was a good match I mean it
took a while for England to kick off the
it's at the start it was after that free
kick rashford got and he scored it
that's really it really brought them up
and they started playing well they got
two goals in around 20 in a 20 minute
Gap and then they played well they
controlled the game they didn't let any
other goals in
yeah and obviously after that England's
success last night hopefully there won't
be too much gloating for your your Welsh
friends coming into school feeling
pretty disappointed this morning no I'll
try not to I'll avoid that try not to
yeah and what's about the game against
Senegal what are you hoping to see
hopefully we do do we do good
um this is Senegal so they're not that
much of a challenging team
so hopefully we should come out with a
win and maybe a win in extra time all
right thank you so much for speaking to
us see I think there's going to be some
very tired children at school today and
obviously among the Wales fans uh pretty
disappointed children as well here yeah
don't break it to that young England fan
but Senegal are a good team don't tell
him
um thanks very much indeed for now
everyone thank you they look like
Shepherds start there next to the
Christmas tree now doctors have hailed a
new era of medicine after a study showed
for the first time that a drug can slow
the early symptoms of Alzheimer's they
say the drug provides evidence dementia
can be treated
the clinical trial results showed that
the canamab slowed the progression of
disease and
[Music]
we believe this provides hope to
patients caregivers and Physicians
stimulates further research into
Alzheimer's and neurodegenerative
diseases and provides evidence that that
it is possible to treat these
devastating
our science correspondent Thomas More is
with us now hi Thomas good morning so
tell us about the science
yeah look you can't overstate the
significance of this moment k for 30
years scientists have been looking at
this Rogue protein called amyloid that
builds up in the brains of people's with
Alzheimer's disease and for those 30
years they've really struggled to find a
drug that does anything to that protein
but now they have one that really works
in this trial the the amount of protein
reduced so much that the patients
wouldn't have actually had a formal
diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease after
18 months of treatment and that had an
impact on their clinical symptoms too it
reduced the mental the progression the
decline in mental agility and memory
that you associated with with
Alzheimer's by 27 and that is hugely
significant the first time that they've
been able to show that and doctors are
optimistic that with longer treatment
that clinical benefit would become more
significant it's not a cure but this
does slow the progression of Alzheimer's
for the first time and allows patients
to spend more time with their families
of course and when will it be available
on the NHS or is that too early to say
well this is really important because
this is going to be a massive challenge
for the NHS at the moment most patients
are diagnosed too late to have this drug
and also the the number of brain scans
called pet scans and also lump lumbar
punctures these are biopsies of the
spinal fluid that are needed to
accurately diagnose Alzheimer's disease
are only given to just one percent of
patients so this is going to need a
revolution in the NHS to actually
deliver but we've been here with
multiple sclerosis in the past with the
treatments that are now available for
that disease and doctors are optimistic
that with some forward planning they can
do the same here it is an expensive drug
this lecanumab but it's worth it in the
long run they say because it would save
on expensive social care okay and when
might it be available I mean obviously
people listening this morning will think
that straight on the phone to the GP
saying I want that drug
yeah
look it's a really important question
Kate and this is a phase three trial now
the the drug company thinks that it's
going to apply for a drug license in the
US early next year and then follow up
with licenses here in the UK and in
Europe that could happen next year too
it takes a while for them to look at the
pros and cons of treatment and this drug
did have side effects it's important to
stress that the potential for brain
bleeds so they need to make sure that
they've got good monitoring in place to
make sure patients can benefit from this
but hopefully it would be here used in
two or three years but again I have to
stress this is just for mild cases early
stage Alzheimer's disease and the NHS
needs to really ramp up to make sure
that patients do have good access to
this drug and finally and just develop
your point there um Thomas we must say
that people have died during these
trials haven't they
yes and you know but the side effects
are are really something that they are
concerned about and they think it's
because these clumps of protein of the
Rogue protein when they're removed from
the brain it does really result in brain
swelling and potentially brain bleeding
so it does need careful monitoring but
in terms of deaths it was about the same
number of people who died in the
treatment group as those who were given
the dummy drug so uh they have to be
looked at very very carefully to make
sure that this can be caught at an early
stage but one doctor said uh last night
if his if he offered this drug to most
patients they would be happy to take
this drug because uh the the the
benefits are so great compared to the
risk this is such a devastating fear
disease of old age that most people
would take this drug and run that risk I
know you're going to develop the stories
throughout the course of the day Thomas
so we will let you go thank you very
much indeed
uh meantime let's tell you about more
winter strikes ambulance workers across
England are likely to join nurses in
going on strike Before Christmas after
voting in favor of industrial action so
what's the plan shingy has more for us
uh from I think Great Ormond Street
Children's Hospital which is one of the
hospitals that could well be impacted
Shinji good morning
good morning Kay that's right Great
Ormond Street hospital will be impacted
by the other strikes which we know are
going ahead the strikes called by the
Royal College of Nursing but on those
ambulance tracks as we understand there
isn't a date set for those yet that they
will involve call handlers that involve
technicians as well as paramedics but
it's worth saying that strike action is
far from unanimous as far as we
understand it and only around 8 out of
200 trust was the threshold the 50
threshold in the ballot met and I think
also there's lots of a lack of some
detail around exactly where in the
country that would happen but as far as
we know that will involve five ambulance
trust and two merseyside Hospital trusts
and that comes following the news of
that nursing strike which I mentioned
which will be the biggest industrial
action by the Royal College of Nursing
who understand around 100 000 staff are
taking strike action on the 15th and the
20th of December with those go ahead
followed by these ambulance strikes or
inside and some close proximity that
will pile the pressure on the NHS in
what is already a really busy winter
period
so I mean the concern is that as you
were saying these these strikes could
well all come along at the same time
What will that mean for their Health
Service
it means serious pressure we understand
that there are serious backlogs in the
NHS and interestingly enough the
ambulance workers striking have pointed
to those they say that they don't just
want wage increases but that there's a
backlog in the NHS and that they need to
have wage increases so that they can
attract more staff and thus cut the
backlog in the NHS if they go ahead
we're looking at really really serious
issues we understand that cancer
hospitals are on the list for the Royal
College of Nursing strikes we also
understand that children's hospitals are
on those people could miss procedures
which they've been waiting a long time
for and really serious and important
procedures like that okay thanks very
much inducing you thank you
and at nine o'clock tomorrow morning
gonna be joined by union leaders
including Mick Lynch the General
Secretary of the rmt and also
um Dave Ward from the communication
Workers Union postal workers union
they'll answer your questions in a
special program as the country faces a
wave of strikes not seen in a generation
you can email your questions to ask the
union leaders at Sky dot UK or send them
to me on Twitter at K Burley lots of
you've already done that this morning
you can send them as a video if you
would like to we've done this as a
series ask thee and I think that you
know if you've got a video or a thought
that you would like to put in a video
then we can play it out to the union
leaders tomorrow morning that's from
nine o'clock in the morning ask the new
union leaders tomorrow at nine
um you've got the email address there
and you can tweet me at K Burley
Now new figures show food prices are
rising at the highest rate on record as
guy correspondent Adele Robinson is in
Oxford for us this morning this is not
what people want to hear just before
Christmas Is It Adele good morning
good morning Kay no it's absolutely not
in fact the survey this morning by the
British retail Consortium has been
described as painting a picture that is
increasingly Bleak it's certainly not
spreading any Christmas cheer this
morning here on Oxford High Street and
what it has shown uh was in November
um prices and items across shops Rose by
7.4 percent higher than they did in
November of last year and that is as you
say a record high at the highest that
the British retail Consortium have
recorded since 2005 so in 17 years
um food particularly perhaps
unsurprisingly has risen by the most
particularly fresh food so the likes of
meat eggs and dairy coffee is also shot
up and also whether things like sports
and recreational items so overall again
painting a picture that Christmas
gifting this year is going to be more
expensive than in recent years and with
the food price inflation though what
it's what driving it particularly again
is a rising energy cost and that's
despite government intervention
government support for households it may
be that actually it's keeping a bit of a
lid on inflation because we are
expecting prices to come down in the new
year so we may be reaching the peak or
if not already at the peak of inflation
but we'll see what happens over the next
couple of months why is this important
well not just because it's painful for
people here on the High Street buying
food and other items but also what
happens with inflation informs what the
bank of England do with interest rates
remember they're trying to keep
inflation down by raising interest rates
and that in turn has a knock-on effect
to mortgage rate so I'm afraid as I said
not much Christmas cheer here on the
High Street this morning no indeed not
going to let you get out of the way of
that backing up Lori thanks very much
indeed Adele thank you there we go thank
you
just coming to get rid of the rubbish
aren't they now tensions between China
and the West have risen in recent months
over Taiwan which Beijing claims as part
of its territory joining us now from the
Taiwanese Capital Taipei is Tobias
Elwood conservative MP and former
Defense Minister chair of the defense
select committee as well of course
um hello to you Mr Elwood thanks for
joining us why are you in Taiwan
well as you were just saying China's
long wanted control of this island it's
important to understand what's going on
here our minds have been focused on
Ukraine but president XI has made it
clear that it will use Force if
necessary to take this island and I
think there are lessons to be learned
from Ukraine we didn't do enough there
to prevent an invasion and we're now
feeling the economic and security
consequences uh China is now getting
more aggressive more assertive and if
president XI fulfills his promise the
impact would be huge it would not just
be United ideological win over democracy
but China would gain a major economic
Powerhouse this here in this country
they meet the advanced semiconductors
that are used right across the world it
would also allow China to dominate the
South China Sea those important shipping
lanes and it would give China momentum
to further pursue its Authority
authoritarian agenda and of course how
would the West look after that losing
another Democratic partner so it's so
important to understand what is going on
here and prepare for what might be
coming over the over the hill
okay
um but as you know Nancy Pelosi the
former speaker a U.S Congress
um went in August she saw caused all
sorts of uh problems with tension
between the Chinese and Taiwan
um how do you think that British
politicians visiting will have any
different impact
well it's important that you mentioned
that it China reacted uh very angrily
wanting to sue any politician from
coming here to see what's going on that
interferes with their plans but there
are 23 million people here who have I
think a very different view about that
and it's important that we understand
what is going on in this Necker there
was us really moved by what our prime
minister said in his Mansion a house
speech to recognize that uh we can't
allow China to be bullying its way in
the same way that Russia has been doing
in Ukraine
um we heard the Prime Minister speaking
about China and relations with the UK
during his mansion house speech of
course
um earlier on in the week and Monday I
think it was
um and he was talking about China being
a challenge and when he spoke to me
earlier in the year he talked about them
being a threat why do you think he's
watered that down
well I mean I really welcomed this
speech it was the first solid foreign
policy statement on China I think for
many many years the so-called Golden Era
of relations with China are now over
this idea that if we do simply more
trade with China they're going to open
up to political reform that clearly
isn't going to happen China under
President she is pursuing a competing
Vision with the West uh that I think
could lead us the world's friendship to
suit two spheres of influence is taking
advantage of the timid West that's
unwilling to date to call China out so
I'm pleased that the Prime Minister
sunak has said this China is expanding
authoritarian influence is enormous
right across the world it needs this to
fuel its own economy so it's so
important that we actually call this
increasingly uh looking like a police
state out and and actually uh stand up
for our rights our values
um the international rule of law
um the Pentagon telling us that China's
doubled its nuclear stockpile in the
last two years that they've conducted
more ballistic missile tests last year
than the rest of the world combined
how much is that sleeping Dragon keeping
an eye on what's happening in Ukraine
well sleeping dragon is a great way to
describe this it's not just this nuclear
Arsenal but it's developing it's Army
it's Air Force it's Navy are now one of
the largest in the world they are
colossal and it's not just the South
China Sea that they're dominating
they're starting to move their assets
and put bases around the world as I say
this is actually competing with the
Western way of life and it's going to
lead eventually to a clash and we've
been asleep of the last you know two or
three decades if you like in seeing uh
China advance but not actually
confirming what we believe is in
allowing them to trade on their own
terms allowing them to advance in ways
that really we should have uh you know
called the check and this is why the
prime minister's statement I think is
the first but we do need to go further
and supporting Taiwan uh need is is got
to be high on the agenda then
I met up with the Ukrainian first lady
Elena zelenski who is in London
yesterday and she told me
um that
they want a special tribunal into
Russian war crimes to be set up and they
want uh the Brits to um have the leading
role in that do you think that is a good
idea how would it work
yes I think this is so important that
any uh Soldier whether it be a you know
a private a sergeant a colonel or Anita
General who's operating under President
Putin recognizes that whatever they do
in Ukraine it could come back to haunt
them and that could only happen if we
collect the evidence if we're able to
put that material together and take it
to the to the the ICC so I think we
should absolutely honor uh the request
uh by the first lady of Ukraine it's
something Britain has done in the past
in places like a Rwanda and indeed
Bosnia and it absolutely needs to happen
here again this isn't just about
defeating Russia on the battlefield it's
making sure that any individual soldiers
that perform these absolute horrendous
atrocities are held to account
and how does that actually work you say
we've done it before with Rwanda and
Bosnia what happens
well you collect the evidence on the day
you make sure that you're able to to
collate those it then also requires
going to the battlefields and afterwards
and making sure that you're able to uh
ascertain what happened there
particularly uh in the uh uh where where
the weapon systems have been used or
there are burial places and so forth uh
taking testimonies and then being able
to put cases forward as to who was
responsible in some ways this is a lot
easier now because uh people are taking
footage with their own mobile phones and
so forth but being able to make the case
of identifying which Russian leaders
which wasn't Russian battle groups and
formations were in what locations at
what time
and why would it be more important to
potentially have the UK involved in the
lead in that as opposed to to other
neighboring countries or indeed other
NATO allies
well we have experiences this as I said
we're also a trusted and fairness in our
judicial process is is well respected
but ultimately we have experience and I
think this is something we can do we've
invested more into Ukraine arguably than
any other European nation in that hour
of need and I think this is another
example of where Britain can lead from
the front again
okay uh thank you very much indeed for
joining us Mr Elwood thank you
thank you
well this is what the first lady told us
yesterday
[Music]
uh
um
foreign
this morning and first lady I'm doing
what I'm sure her husband would want to
be doing but he meantime is speaking to
the nation at nightly
he is and his address last night really
underlined the fact that well yes it's
winter here it's freezing cold there's
no pause in the fighting the Russian
troops they've had these significant
setbacks over the last few months in the
East and also in the South and yet the
president was saying that they are
attacking Ukrainian forces and in harkiv
which is that region that the ukrainians
we captured huge sways of territory from
back in September also in the donbass
and he said um cryptically that he
thought that they were preparing for
something in the South as well the south
is obviously where we've seen in the
last few weeks that significant Victory
by Ukrainian forces pushing the Russians
out of Herson City the only Regional
Capital that fell to the Russians since
their full-scale invasion in February so
this is a country still very much under
attack still very much in need of
support from the west and you've got
NATO foreign ministers meeting at the
moment in Romania and the Ukrainian
foreign secretary or foreign minister is
also there obviously not a member of
NATO but very much reliant on these
allies and saying that the ukrainians
need Patriot air defense systems more
powerful systems from the West that have
yet to been granted and also
Transformers and that is a reflection of
how Russia has been hitting as well as
the front line this new energy front
line hitting power stations across
Ukraine trying to turn off the power and
the ukrainians really need Transformers
to help them as they reconnect the grid
and try to keep the power on okay for
now thank you
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen you can listen to the latest
edition of The Sky News Daily podcast
with Neil today speaking to our security
and defense editor Deborah just there
about how they continued Russian
shelling is affecting Ukraine's power
grid
still to come on the program as postal
workers begin a fresh two-day strike
talking to the boss of the Royal Mail
Simon Thompson how's it going to fix it
paramedics are set to join notice in
walkouts after voting to strike speaking
to the interim chief of tech of NHS
providers that's saffron caudry and
Labor's Shadow immigration Minister
Stephen kinnick is with me soon after
eight o'clock
before that some of today's other
headlines for you and a fresh wave of
strikes is being staged today as Royal
Mail workers lecturers and also College
staff stage walkouts around the country
overpay jobs and conditions picket lines
will be mounted outside universities six
forms and Royal Mail centers as more
action that is planned in the run-up to
Christmas
the founder of the right wing oath
Keeper's militia has been found guilty
of seditious conspiracy for his
involvement in the 6th of January attack
on the U.S Capitol last year Stuart
Rhodes instigated a plot to forcefully
block Congress from certifying the
victory of democrat Joe Biden over
Donald Trump in 2020 presidential
election
half of all free-range turkeys produced
for Christmas in the UK have been cold
or have died due to bird flu the British
poultry Council told MPS that 600 000
out of about 1.3 million birds have been
lost the government recently ordered all
poultry and captive birds in England to
be kept indoors due to the worst avian
flu outbreak on record
now the boss of British gas owner
centrica has told Sky News that more
Retail Energy suppliers will probably go
boss this winter this winter Chris
O'Shea also warned that the UK remains
more vulnerable to energy shortages than
its European neighbors he's been
speaking to our business correspondent
Paul Kelso
the first test of Britain's energy
resilience has come as expected from the
weather but at the easington gas
terminal on humberside it's not the cold
that has led to gas being brought
onshore and out of storage for the first
time this winter
this is the rough gas pipeline it runs
from here 18 miles out to sea to the
storage facility but now for the first
time since it reopened it's bringing gas
in in the other direction it's because
of the weather it's overcast it's still
and it's cold there's very little solar
or wind power being generated so the
National Grid has called for gas to come
in through this pipe and it's on its way
to fire power stations and homes and
businesses
centrica reopened the rough storage
field in September as the government
scrambled to shore up supplies
the chief executive says it will help
keep the lights on
so that wasn't the other day we'd have
to look for alternative sources of gas
or we'd have to look for ways to cut the
electricity consumption but definitely
the price would have gone up simple
economic supply and demand if demand
goes up and Supply doesn't go up then
prices increase so this is keeping
prices down just under two bar to go so
we're not far off
even with the rough storage facility
open the UK has only nine days supply of
gas in reserve a fraction of our
European neighbors Europe has a
significantly higher gas stores than we
do
um Germany France and Italy they've all
got a significantly more ability to keep
grass in their below sea or Subterranean
and reservoirs Central is the UK's
largest domestic supplier as well as an
oil and gas producer and the boss's
warning its competitors may not make it
through the winter there are a number of
energy suppliers in the precarious
financial position and and that's just
getting worse every day every day that
they make more losses they get in a
worse position the risk of failure
increases and and I I really worry that
we're going to see more failures by and
large they're owned by wealthy
individuals who have a free bet if this
goes right they will make even more
money than they have to be and if it
goes wrong our customers have to pick up
the cost that cannot be right
easington can handle 20 of the UK's gas
needs next door a Norwegian pipeline
supplying another 30 percent makes
landfall the UK needs every molecule
this winter Paul Kelso Sky News on
humberside
let's return to one of our top stories
we now the chair of the commons defense
select committee has backed a call from
Ukraine's first lady for the UK to lead
the way in the creation of a special
International tribunal to prosecute
Russia for aggression against her Nation
here's what Tobias Elwood told us just a
little earlier
this is so important that any uh Soldier
whether it be a uh you know a private a
sergeant a colonel or indeed a general
who's operating under President Putin
recognizes that whatever they do in
Ukraine it could come back to haunt them
and that could only happen if we collect
the evidence if we're able to put that
material together and take it to the to
the the ICC so I think we should
absolutely honor uh the request uh by
the first lady of Ukraine uh it's
something Britain has done in the past
in places like a Rwanda and indeed
Bosnia and it absolutely needs to happen
here again this isn't just about
defeating Russia on the battlefield it's
making sure that any individual soldiers
that perform these absolute horrendous
atrocities are held to account
tomorrow is with us to talk about all
matters politic this morning hi um
tomorrow so the first lady we've seen a
lot of her while she's been here of
Ukraine and she wants Britain to go
further in their help that's right she
gave this incredibly powerful address to
parliamentarians yesterday afternoon
talking about some of the horrors that
she had seen and encountered during the
conflict including sexual violence as a
weapon of War some really harrowing
stories that she touched on there and
she said that she wanted Britain to take
the lead in setting up a special
prosecutor because she said it's of
course hugely important that human
rights abuses in this conflict are
documented and people eventually brought
to Justice and the criticism of the
international criminal court in The
Hague is that only I think two rape
cases over the past 20 years have been
prosecuted and the demand from the
Ukrainian government is that a special
prosecutor is set up just for this as it
was for the conflict in Rwanda and then
in Bosnia just take evidence on this
subject we know Dominic Robb has already
looked at trying to help with get
evidence Gathering is the Justice
secretary for potential legal action in
the future but she wants Britain to take
the lead on that and we'll be uh
pressing the government as to what
they're going to do to help them but the
government's response so far has been
supportive okay tomorrow for now thanks
so much indeed tomorrow's take of course
at nine o'clock looking forward to that
thank you now a fresh wave of strikes is
beginning as the year of industrial
action continues across the country
Royal Mail workers University lecturers
sixth form staff are taking part in
walkouts today joined Now by Simon
Thompson Chief exec at the Royal Mail
um hello to Mr Thompson thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
when are you going to get these posties
back to work
well the first thing I would say is I
just want to offer a huge apology to our
customers both our retail customers that
trust us to deliver things to the door
and also our customers that receive
things at the door and the other thing I
would just like to make really really
clear is that we are doing absolutely
everything we can to make sure that we
protect Christmas whilst the CW
leadership are doing everything they can
to destroy Christmas in terms of our
posties we've offered them a nine
percent uh pay increase that's a cost of
400 million pounds for us as a business
and that's 400 million pounds when we're
losing 1.2 million pounds a day we
really do feel that that is fair and the
other thing as well I would add is that
we've been accused by the CW of want to
be a gig economy business and this again
is totally not true you know we have 97
permanent employment we pay 18 to 14
more than the industry norm and I even
offered them the opportunity of having a
campaign to get on improving the
standards in the industry and they
turned me down on that I also offered
them the opportunity of a profit
sharesky and they also turned me down on
that and on my way in this morning I was
listening to the radio and I heard one
of our customers biscateers who were
very very clear in their asks which is
they want us to give a seven day
delivery service for Parcels they want
us to be able to deliver those Parcels
overnight and they were also very very
clear that this disruption after
Christmas is really not good for their
customers and is not good for their
business
um you listed some of the things that
the union has been accusing you of trust
me when I tell you that the leader of
the Union was on the program last week
accusing you more of that said than that
saying that his members uh were being
um intimidated by
um the Royal Mail in order to do things
they didn't want to do
you know I'm actually pleased that you
raised that point because on strike
action days we've seen some
extraordinary behaviors we've had
allegations of racism we've had
allegations of sexism we've had people
threatened with violence we've had
people actually suffering actual
violence it's an extraordinary situation
and it's not something that we will ever
tolerate we have some cases that are
currently going through our processes
and we will be taking action as is
required okay so you've been accused of
sexism and racism
um what would you say are you
no as I said that we have had some
allegations and we take these things
very very seriously and we make sure
that if there's anybody that is not
behaving correctly regardless of who
they are in the organization I would add
that they are dealt with in the most
Swift and best way possible okay thank
you for clarifying that also um Mr Ward
the union leader went on to say he
challenged you actually on my program
last week to say
come and sit down and meet with him at
any stage to try to get this resolved
we have been talking for seven months to
try and get this situation resolved
around change and for the first six
months the union did not engage in those
discussions at all I then offered them
the opportunity of joining me with acass
and I have to say that did eventually
happen and a big thank you to the team
of acas I thought they were professional
and dedicated to try and help us resolve
this situation it took the CWU nearly a
month to take me up on that offer we
then spent three weeks in intensive
talks including weekends which I also
participated in and at the end of that
they rejected our change agenda
completely out of hand
um Ward said that he would come on this
program at any time to debate with you
will you come on and debate with him on
the program
I think that what we need to be spending
our time on that's a yes or no answer Mr
Thompson he's prepared to come on the
program you say you want to get this
sorted out can you come on the program
and discuss it with him
I think what we need to be dedicating
our time on here is executing the agenda
for change that we need so we can
compete and win in the market we've
given our final offer it is not
something that is negotiable but I'm
more than happy to meet Mr Ward to
discuss our final offer I think that
what the CWU are doing is they are
distracting away from the actual core of
the issue here the core of the issue
here is that we used to be a letters
business we are now a Parcels business
we've spent 900 million pounds on
investment so we can compete and win in
the market and as for the business plan
here is the business plan that the CWU
actually offered me on one piece of
paper it is not costed it has no
timelines I question whether this is
actually at all credible okay well Mr
Ward's coming on the program tomorrow
um you are very welcome to come on and
join in if not then you know you're
giving him a free reign that's up to you
let me ask you briefly Before I Let You
Go I can't post is have the England flag
on their vans
well what I would say is that we support
everyone and every team and we're making
sure that our team can have time to
watch the games as they wish and that's
for absolutely every team I think in
terms of flags on Vans I'm afraid it's a
safety issue and a safety question and
so therefore we have to make sure we
keep people safe but we definitely wish
every team well and any of our posters
that would like to watch those games we
hope that they definitely enjoy them
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much India for joining us much
appreciated maybe I'll see you tomorrow
thank you very much thank you now
ambulance workers are also set to
striking England Before Christmas with
unison the latest Union to ballot for
industrial action joined now by the
interim Chief exec of NHS providers at
saffron caudry
um hello to you thank you for joining us
on the program
um how will my viewers be affected by
strikes by ambulance workers
well we know it's an incredibly
pressured time across the NHS at the
moment in any case and I think what we
are looking at now is is a ramping up of
that pressure but what we do know and
what trust leaders who are members of my
organization are focusing on is how we
minimize the impact on patients and
those seeking the support of the
ambulance service and they're our tried
and tested plans in place to deal with
situations where staff aren't available
so so those
um challenges to patients will be
minimized as far as possible but it's
fair to say that this is going to be a
difficult period ahead
what tried and tested plans are you
talking about there
so we're talking about the kind of
um emergency preparedness plans that
have been tested over the last few weeks
with the operation arctic willow which
is an exercise that looks at combining
both
um winter pressures with the um
pressures of strike action from nurses
and ambulance services so there's you
know making sure that trusts are as
prepared as possible but also the kind
of
um
exercises and plans that are put in
place to respond to any emergency where
it looks like
um ambulances and other parts of the
Health Service will not be available so
um these these kind of contingency plans
are are put in place on an ongoing basis
so operation Arctic willow does that
involve the army
um what we know is that the Army stands
ready to help
um if it is needed I think it's clear
that as we saw during covid it's really
helpful when when the Armed Forces can
step in I think that the role they
played during covid was very much
um supporting supporting other services
with things like vaccinations and I
think the reality is that that if the
army or other Armed Forces step in it's
going to be very much at the margins
rather than
um going out and driving ambulances
um so there will be a role if they are
needed but that isn't going to be the
central plan do we know when this
industrial action might be because
feasibly of course two weeks notice for
a strike we could see that the ambulance
workers and nurses are on strike at the
same time what sort of problems will
that cause
well we don't yet know when when these
strikes will be obviously um it's
possible isn't it
it's it's a possibility and you know
that would be very challenging for the
NHS as we know
um but we don't yet know when this
strike action will take place so I think
it's fair to say that the NHS plans for
all eventualities of course
um but we we don't know when that strike
action is going to happen because they
announced the the results of the ballot
have only just been announced last night
yeah but they need two weeks so they
could buy if they announce it possibly
Thursday then feasibly tomorrow they
feasibly could do that why do you think
that four percent pay rise is enough
sorry I couldn't hear your question I'm
so sorry I was asking about a four
percent pay rise why is that enough
um we're not as NHS providers we're not
an organization that that sets whether
uh the pay rise is enough or it isn't
that's for the government to negotiate
our trust leaders on in a position to
negotiate that pay rise or any pay rise
or terms and conditions with with NHS
staff that's very much a government
issue what our trust leaders are
focusing on is how they manage the
impact of this strike and and support
their staff as well
do you think it's enough
I think it's that is very much a
situation for the government of what I
would say is that we know that NHS staff
whether they're nurses whether they're
ambulance staff paramedics and and
indeed doctors have are are feeling the
impact of inflation the cost of living
and the very real challenges that that
many workers across the country are
facing at the moment and they have been
through a very significant period of
intensive working during the pandemic so
we understand why they are are seeking a
paywall but that's very much for for the
government to to focus on and what we
have to remember is that there are some
really core underlying issues here
around Workforce shortages that need to
be addressed by the government so we
need to see a proper long-term plan for
the workforce that's got the money
behind it to put that into place because
right now we've got vacancies of around
100 hundred and thirty thousand across
the NHS and that isn't sustainable to
run a service
okay good to see you this morning thank
you
thank you and uh just a reminder nine
o'clock tomorrow joined by union leaders
including Mick Lynch the General
Secretary of the rmt and Dave Ward from
the communication workers unit who are
on strike uh we just were speaking
actually to the head of the Royal Mail
um will he come in and join them
unlikely but certainly Dave Wood said
that he would be happy to debate with
him at any stage the prime reason for
the guys coming in is that they're going
to be answering your questions in a
special program as the country faces a
wave of strikes not seen in a generation
you can email your questions to ask the
union leaders at sky.uk or send them to
me on Twitter at Cape early lots of you
doing that already and you can also send
them as a video question if you would
prefer ask the union leaders tomorrow at
9 00 a.m do you have a brick bat or
perhaps a bouquet for them in question
form let me know
now it was a night of celebration for
England but a heartbreak for Wales as
the Lions knocked the dragons out of the
World Cup beating them three nil in the
second half
let's talk about it should we in more
detail Josie green who plays for the
Wales women's team and Leicester city is
with us now it's good to see you did you
have any divided loyalty given that you
play for an English England Club but
you're obviously
um Welsh
no not at all I've played for the Welsh
national team since I was 14 and
um it really holds a special place in my
heart and you know I'm Welsh through and
through I play for the national team and
I was really gutted to see the result go
the way that it did
um how do you think they'll be feeling
this morning
as a player I really think they'll be
gutted
um it's such a shame the World Cup has
gone as it has I think that things
didn't click on the pitch for them the
whole world cup and I think the players
themselves
um know that Joe Allen said that in his
interview that you know things weren't
working for them and the game against
England was going to be the biggest game
of his career and I think that it's a
it's a real shame that the result went
the way that it did
um the first half I mean they they I'm
not sure if it was because they were
playing well or England weren't playing
as well
um it was certainly as they say in
football parlance a game of two halves
yes absolutely and Rob page went into
the game
um with a different system and you could
see that clearly Wales went with a back
four and it really kept England at Bay
for the first half
um and it's just a shame that you know
it was a tale of two halves in the
second half for whatever reason it
didn't work for them and and England
came out on top
how well do you think England played
I think the changes that Gareth
Southgate made and you know the likes of
Phil foden and Marcus rashford both
getting goals I think you can see the
depth in their squad and I think that's
going to be key for them moving forward
and I think the first half I don't think
they played well but you could see the
moments of quality that they did have in
the second half and that made all the
difference
it sure did how do you think they'll do
against Senegal
it would be a really tough match
um you can see in this world cup that
any team can beat anyone and and you
have to be good on your day and the
consistency in England I'm not sure that
we've seen it as much as maybe other
clubs in the world other teams in the
World Cup
um
I think it'll be a tough game if I was
going to predict I might go it going to
extra time and I think they're going to
make it in the
um extra time but yeah tough game for
them Brazil I think and France is still
favorites to lift the trophy what's your
prediction
I think in my opinion Brazil
um have got a great Squad they've got
great Squad debt
um you know
if you've got the likes of Neymar
hopefully coming back from injury as
well and they've looked really
impressive so far
um as well with France I think they also
look really good in the tournament but
do they have the hunger and desire
having you know won a recent World Cup
um I think that's my only question I
have to ask to them
okay well it's um great to talk to you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning thank you thank you um of
course
it's the weekend isn't it am I right in
saying it is Sunday when we play Senegal
I think I'm right in saying that I'm
sure if I'm not somebody will correct me
[ __ ] and Maya tell me that I am ha
let's have a look at what's happening
with Mariah Carey
[Music]
Mariah Carey a new study suggests that
bats are extreme when it comes to sound
production and have a greater vocal rage
than singers like Mariah Carey is such a
I can't believe I'm reading this
researchers from the University of
Southern Denmark filmed what goes on in
a bat's voice box for the first time
ever and found that the normal vocal
range for about spans seven octaves
speaking of how many octaves you can
span we've got
Jersey Boys Frankie Valley the number of
octaves that he could span talking about
that uh in the nine o'clock hour we're
all very excited about that time now
though for a look at some of the photos
that have caught our eye today here we
go big day for Britain's Grand Slam
champ Emma radakanu she was at Windsor
collecting her MBA from the King for
services to tennis the male have worked
out how much her do your outfit cost any
guesses how much that do your outfit
might have cost she is a millionaire
tennis player of course
9400 pounds
wow indeed Matt that belt alone is worth
nearly 1500 pounds for a belt can you
imagine no expense spared when meeting
his majesty obviously I mean picking a
belt up and it's got a price tag of 1500
quid and go oh yeah I love that look at
this uh almost apocalyptic glow on the
horizon in Hawaii lava flows now over
two and a half miles long as the world's
largest active volcano continues its
first eruption in nearly 40 years
officials warning people should stay
away even if there's no immediate threat
to communities and if you need a cool
down after that blistering heat how
about a quick trip to the lovely Market
town of Sterling that's a great
photograph isn't it
um
beautiful winter morning if you can
recognize this Landmark Tower peeking
out from under the fog it's the Wallace
Tower commemorating the 13th century
Scottish hero
depicted by which a picture wasn't here
I can't remember his name the um
somebody tell me help me out with the
Hollywood hero who I was uh Wallace
nope nope nope Lucy has nothing for me
this time now with a fresh wave on
Industrial action being staged coming up
in just a few moments time I'm going to
be speaking to Labor's Shadow home
office Minister and that is Stephen
kinnick uh there's so many strikes that
we need to tell you about the posters
are on strike again we've just been
speaking to the head of Royal Mail he
said we are no longer a letter service
what we are is um a post office as that
deals with um parcels and that's what
the posters have to reckon with they say
come around the table and talk to us
we've invited them both on the program
tomorrow let's see what happens as far
as that concerned don't forget ask the
union leaders is it nine o'clock
tomorrow we have got the leader of the
rmt and other leaders on the program
have you got a question at K Burley let
me know I'll put it to them see you in a
second
[Music]